die nachrichten des tages heute mit
niedrigen jury schönen guten abend
wieder zusammen mit christian otto hier
und du bringst uns heute einen
schillernden neuzugang in der bundesliga
von liverpool nach münchen meine ist der
guten abend ja und das findet sich auch
gleich in unseren themen überblick
wieder
verheerendes erdbeben mehr als 1000 tote
in afghanistan die taliban bitten um
internationale hilfe
ban sanierung und viele fragen der bund
will das marode schienennetz
modernisieren kritiker nennen die pläne
substanzlos und
[Musik]
transfer-coup perfekt weltklasse stürmer
sah die oma nie unterschreibt bei bayern
münchen
[Musik]
mehr als 1000 tote und mindestens
1500 verletzt nach einem schweren
erdbeben in afghanistan vor etwa einem
jahr schaute die welt auf dieses land
als die nato-truppen überstürzt abziehen
mussten seitdem regieren die
islamistischen taliban die jetzt mit
dieser naturkatastrophe fertig werden
müssen das beben mit der stärke 5,9
ereignete sich vergangene nacht im osten
des landes an der grenze zu pakistan
die provinzen kost und praktika sind
besonders betroffen weil die regionen
abgelegen sind lief hilfe zunächst
schleppend an mehr von jörg brase
viele sitzen nur noch apathisch vor den
trümmern ihrer häuser
andere halten verletzte warten dass
endlich hilfe kommt noch immer bergen
sie opfer aus den zerstörten gebäuden
das beben überraschte sie im schlaf
viele starben in ihren betten
aus der dünnbesiedelten bergregion
kommen nur spärlich bilder nach draußen
sie zeigen chaos und zerstörung
mit bloßen händen gruben viele nach
ihren angehörigen und die wenigen
hilfsorganisationen die noch im land
sind stehen vor großen problemen es
regnet und das telefonnetz bricht oft
zusammen auch ist die lage in den
wenigen krankenhäusern der region sehr
schlecht
der zugang zu informationen per telefon
oder internet ist ein problem und auch
der zugang zu der region
es sind oft nur schotterstraßen wer dort
die bergdörfer will kommt dort nur sehr
schwierig hin
die regierung der radikalislamischen
taliban kamen der hauptstadt kabul zu
einem krisentreffen zusammen und
versprach den betroffenen schnelle hilfe
familien die tote zu beklagen haben
bekommen von der regierung jeweils
100.000 afghani knapp 1100 euro und
familien mit verletzten rund 550 euro
außerdem ist ein medizinisches
versorgungszentrum
eingetroffen das international geächtete
taliban regime hat selbst nicht viele
mittel so traf das beben ein land in
einer sowieso schon dramatischen
humanitären lage
afghanistan gehört zum berichts gebiet
unseres istanbul korrespondent jörg
brase jörg afghanistan ist ein politisch
instabiles land die taliban
international isoliert wie schnell kann
denn unter diesen umständen
internationale hilfe anlaufen
nur die taliban haben diese
internationale hilfe ja selbst
angefordert und deshalb kann man glaube
ich davon ausgehen dass sie sowohl den
helfern als auch den hilfsgütern keine
steine in den weg legen werden ganz im
gegenteil sind sie sind auf diese hilfe
angewiesen auch deshalb weil der
nationale markt in sehr schlechtem
zustand ist ob nahrungsmittel aufdecken
ob zelte vor allem aber medikamente und
medizinisches spezialgerät das ist auf
dem markt im land kaum noch oder wenn
dann nur zu sehr hohen preisen zu
bekommen teilweise auch als defekt der
internationalen sanktionen gegen das
taliban-regime und zu haben der
hilfsorganisation mit denen wir heute
gesprochen haben gesagt dass sie mit
einer sehr langen hilfsmission rechnet
über viele wochen wenn nicht sogar
monate weil diese hilfsgüter wegen der
schlechten infrastruktur oder sehr
schwer zu den menschen gebracht werden
können die in teilweise sehr entlegenen
und schwer erreichbaren regionen leben
vielen dank für diese hintergründe jörg
brase
krieg und klima es sind diese über
großen themen die die welt aktuell stark
verändern und die anstehenden gipfel von
eu g7 und nato prägen werden welchen
beitrag will berlin leisten dazu
erklärte sich kanzler scholz heute im
bundestag er sport deutschland und den
westen auf einen langen konflikt mit
russland ein und brachte einen marshall
plan für die ukraine ins spiel patrizia
wiedemeier
vor dem eu den g 7 und dem nato gipfel
klare botschaften des bundeskanzlers die
nato partner und auch die ukraine
könnten sich auf deutschland verlassen
die ukraine erhalte weiterhin waffen und
finanzielle hilfen sie gehöre zu europa
deshalb werbe ich werde ich mich auch
beim europäischen rat morgen und
übermorgen mit allem nachdruck dafür
einsetzen dass die gesamte eu
geschlossen ja sagt
27 mal ja zum kandidatenstatus der
kanzler mache der ukraine mit aussagen
wie dieser falsche hoffnungen kritisiert
die linke wie soll denn ein land auf
dass es raketen regnet über 35 beitrags
kapitel und mehr als hundert tausend
seiten des rechts bestandes der eu
verhandeln die debatte meine damen und
herren über den beitritt der ukraine in
die eu ist eine scheindebatte die union
dagegen begrüßt die beitrittsperspektive
ebenso dass olaf scholz endlich in
kiefer und das nun schwere waffen
geliefert werden fordert aber weitere
anstrengungen
[Applaus]
ausdrücklich dass man auch endlich die
lieferung der waffen in gang kommt die
wir hier gemeinsam am 28 april im
deutschen bundestag mit sehr großer
mehrheit
beschlossen haben und die sie schon seit
wochen ankündigen und ja wir alle hätten
uns mit sicherheit gewünscht dass das
schneller geht wir alle bedauern das ist
dass reaktionen gibt die
ausbildungszeiten wie die verfügbarkeit
von materialien umso wichtiger dass die
ersten schweren waffen jetzt auch in der
ukraine angekommen sind auch wenn ein
ende des krieges nicht in sicht ist
kündigte olaf scholz einen marshallplan
für den wiederaufbau der ukraine an
sicherlich auch ein thema des kommenden
gipfel marathon
wir alle erleben rekord energiepreise
extreme lieferschwierigkeiten und eine
hohe inflation weswegen finanzminister
lindner im zdf vor einer sehr ernst zu
nehmenden wirtschaftskrise warnte
trotzdem plant die fdp ab kommendem jahr
unbedingt die schuldenbremse einzuhalten
und von spd und grünen kommen mehrere
vorschläge für weitere entlastungen der
bürger ob das zusammenpasst über die
fährten ampel fronten britta buchholz
am morgen suchen erstaunlich viele
kabinettsmitglieder die nähe des
finanzministers gesprächsbedarf vor dem
koalitionsausschuss denn die ampel es
zunehmend uneins bei der frage wie
welches geld ausgegeben wird
gleichzeitig werden bei spd und grünen
die stimmen lauter angesichts der hohen
inflation die menschen zu unterstützen
es ist völlig klar dass neben den
entlastungs paketen die auch im herbst
erst volle wirkung entfalten wir weiter
über entlastung sprechen müssen ich
glaube dass gerade im hinblick auf die
grundsicherung
wir uns hier verständigen müssen dass
menschen die extrem leiden und es nicht
kompensieren können
unterstützung brauchen zwei entlastungs
paket von knapp 30 milliarden euro gibt
es schon und nun etliche ideen für
weitere entlastung zum beispiel eine
verlängerung des 9 euro tickets ein
preis deckel für den grundbedarf bei
strom und gas oder eine absenkung der
mehrwertsteuer zum beispiel auf obst und
gemüse nur wie soll das finanziert
werden wir können uns neue schulden
nicht mehr leisten wir zahlen bereits so
viele zinsen für die alten schulden
jetzt dass eine weitere
verschuldungspolitik zu höheren steuern
führen müsste am abend im kanzleramt
wird es wohl besonders um die
schuldenbremse gehen die fdp will daran
festhalten
spitzenpolitiker von spd und grünen
dagegen nicht
mehr als acht millionen menschen sind
seit dem 24 februar aus der ukraine
geflohen meldet heute die un
flüchtlingshilfe und weitere millionen
fliehen innerhalb des landes zum
beispiel aus der ost ukraine wo die
heftigsten kämpfe weiter um die
strategisch wichtigen städte ließ hans
gonska wir odon jetzt geführt werden
russland verschärft zum heutigen
jahrestages des nazi angriffs auf die
sowjetunion bin ton richtung berlin mehr
von lena sünder bruch vor exakt 81
jahren überfiel nazi deutschland die
sowjetunion den gedenktag nimmt das
russische außenministerium zum anlass
den ton berlin gegenüber zu verschärfen
deutsche regierungsmitglied würden
russen feindliche hysterie schüren in
der ukraine geht derweil der massive
russische beschuss weiter distanz in der
region luhansk ist noch vollständig
unter ukrainischer kontrolle doch die
truppen verteidigen eine verlassene
stadt mit veralteten raketenwerfern
diese bilder sollen pro russische
separatisten zeigen nur 20 kilometer
entfernt
wir werden weiterhin in ihre linien
eindringen und sie vollständig
einzukesseln und ich denke wenn sie
keine idioten sind werden sie sich
ergeben wenn sie nicht kapitulieren
wollen werden sie sterben
mit einer eroberung der städte lässig
und jetzt würde russland die gesamte
region lohans kontrollieren und könnte
weiter in der angrenzenden region
donetsk vorrücken den pro-russischen
separatisten zu hilfe kommen die nach
britischen angaben hohe verluste
erlitten haben nicht nur den osten auf
den norden hat die russische armee
wieder ins visier genommen in der region
gibt es brutalen und zynischen
russischen artilleriebeschuss das wird
den besatzern nichts bringen aber die
russische armee ist taub für jede
rationalität
mariupol die hafenstadt am schwarzen
meer steht bereits seit rund einem monat
unter russischer kontrolle im
blockierten hafen stecken immer noch
etliche tonnen weizen fest doch nun soll
nach türkisch russischen gesprächen
erstmals seit mai ein typischer frachter
den hafen verlassen haben ob er getreide
geladen hat ist aber unklar
das war es die regierung in bulgarien
ist am ende das parlament hat
ministerpräsident beck oft mit einem
misstrauensvotum gestürzt er war erst
seit einem halben jahr im amt und steht
für eine pro westliche politik der
staatspräsident hdf muss jetzt nach
neuen mehrheiten suchen und
möglicherweise gibt es bald neuwahlen
wie weiter mit den kostenlosen corona
bürger tests die den staat viel geld
kosten gesundheitsminister lauterbach
spd ist für weitere tests will sie aber
einschränken und auch dass die länder
sich an den kosten beteiligen
bayerns ressortchef holetschek csu weist
das zurück mit dem hinweis dass sie
schon die impfzentren finanzierten die
gratis märz laufen ende des monats
monats aus
so wie es ist kann es nicht bleiben sagt
verkehrsminister wissen über das
schienennetz der deutschen bahn und
kündigte heute eine generalsanierung an
ab 2024 sollen demnach besonders
belastete streckenabschnitte komplett
saniert werden damit sie auf jahre frei
von baustellen sind und die strecken
sollen wo es denn nötig ist gleich zu
einem sogenannten
hochleistungsnetz ausgebaut werden
allerdings wie das ganze finanziert
werden soll das blieb erst einmal unklar
carsten behrendt berichtet
verspätete personenzüge und hunderte
güterwaggons die gegen einer rekordzahl
an baustellen tagelang stecken bleiben
das deutsche bahnnetz ist überlastet der
verkehrsminister macht das thema zur
chefsache und kündigt ein
hochleistungsnetz an den anforderungen
an die schiene werden wir nur mit einem
solchen hochleistungsnetz gerecht es
geht aber nicht um flickwerk sondern
erstmals und die großflächige zeitnah
modernisierung eines netzes seit
jahrzehnten wird zu wenig repariert zu
zaghaft investiert und kaum
digitalisiert aktuell stuft die bahn
zehn prozent ihres netzes rund 3500
kilometer als hoch belastet ein bis 2030
könnten daraus 9000 kilometer werden
mit großflächigen bau korridoren will
die bahn nun gleichzeitig sanieren und
modernisieren unser fokus ist die
erreichung der verkehrs und
klimapolitischen ziele der
bundesregierung
kritiker halten die pläne für zu
unkonkret vor allem weil nicht gesagt
wurde was die maßnahmen kosten sollen es
hat uns die substanz gefehlt
deswegen hat ankündigungen gemacht hat
aber nicht erklärt wie das zukünftig
geschehen soll es fehlte jegliche
aussage zu der frage der finanzierung es
gibt grobe abschätzungen die also sagen
dass der zusätzliche finanzbedarf dort
im bereich von 130 bis 150 milliarden
euro liegen könnte und zurzeit stellt
der bund eben zwei milliarden euro an
neuen mitteln zur verfügung und da kann
man also sehen dass derzeit die
mittelbereitstellung nicht passt zu den
bedarf los gehen soll es mit den
großbaustellen erst 2024 mit schnellen
verbesserungen ist also vorerst nicht zu
rechnen
jetzt zur klimapolitik der eu vor zwei
wochen scheiterten wichtige teile des
großen eu klimapakets im parlament ein
wesentlicher streitpunkt der
emissionshandel damit will man den
ausstoß von treibhausgasen
regulieren heute jetzt ein neuer anlauf
ergebnis zustimmung zu einem kompromiss
die kostenlose vergabe von co2
zertifikaten soll jetzt spätestens 2002
und 30 auslaufen im ersten gescheiterten
entwurf für eine längere übergangsphase
vorgesehen die eu will den co2 ausstoß
bis 2030 um 55 prozent verringern
keine guten nachrichten gab es heute für
die belegschaft von ford in saarlouis
die zentrale in den usa hat sich gegen
das saarland und für valencia in spanien
als neuen standort für die produktion
von elektroautos entschieden dort sind
die personalkosten deutlich niedriger
gut 4600 beschäftigte bangen jetzt um
ihre zukunft aus saarlouis susanne
freitag
die wut ist groß mehrere tausend
mitarbeiter waren zur
betriebsversammlung gekommen um
offiziell zu hören was viele schon
geahnt hatten hier in saarlouis werden
sie für ford keine autobahn
man weiß im ersten augenblick nicht wie
es weitergeht ja man hat existenzängste
die begleiten ein die kleinen alle
mitarbeiter hier ford hatte die
standorte saarlouis und valencia in
spanien in einen internen wettbewerb
geschickt wer das attraktivste konzept
anbietet darf das e auto bauen salou jat
verloren spanien sei günstiger hieß es
von unternehmensseite
habe natürlich auf einen fairen prozess
gehabt er war nicht da vor der oper hat
nachher für sich entschieden am schluss
kommt natürlich darauf eindruck auf dass
sie schon längst entschieden haben uns
nur nase herumgeführt haben saarlands
ministerpräsidentin anke rehlinger ist
sauer die entscheidung eine farce sagt
sie sie hatte persönlich mit der ford
spitze verhandelt ein schlag für die
region die von einem strukturwandel
prozess in den nächsten taumelt in salou
hatten sie gehofft zentrum der e
mobilität zu werden und jetzt wir haben
immer für die arbeitsplätze gekämpft
nicht in aller erster linie für einen
automobilhersteller und wenn er dazu
nicht mehr willens oder in der lage ist
dann wenn wir uns nach alternativen
umsehen denn die verantwortung die haben
wir für die beschäftigten in diesem land
und für die wollen wir arbeitsplätze
sichern bis 2025 sind ihre jobs in
saarlouis noch sicher danach ist die
zukunft ungewiss das beispiel ford macht
deutlich dass auf dem weg zur neuen
mobilität auch arbeitsplätze auf der
strecke bleiben können
wir machen jetzt mit dem sport weiter
christin es gibt ein knüller transfer
sei die ist jetzt endlich war den bayern
das sagen zumindest die bayern für die
jürgen klopp vermisst ihn schon aber wir
dürfen nicht darüber nachdenken was wir
jetzt verlieren sondern feiern was wir
hatten so liverpools trainer voller
dankbarkeit manet einer der weltbesten
fußball profis unterschrieb in münchen
einen vertrag bis 2025
der fc bayern inszeniert sich mit der
verpflichtung des 30 jährigen
senegalesen als große bühne des
weltfußballs ist es klar wer hier der
star ist während der bisherige torjäger
robert lewandowski den verein gerne
verlassen würde kann es kaum erwarten
solange der trainer mich nicht als
verteidiger oder torwart einsetzt spiele
ich jede position für ihn und für den
club fans gesagt
foto körper so
23 tore erzielte man nie in der letzten
saison für den fc liverpool mit dem er
auch das champions league finale
erreichte gewinnen konnte er die trophäe
im team von jürgen klopp 2009 10
ich finde aber einer von denen die sich
nicht als star sehen für mich ist das
team der star
die ablösesumme soll bei deutlich über
30 millionen euro liegen
soll die verpflichtung des stürmers
sebastian all er von ajax amsterdam
unter bevorstehen nach übereinstimmenden
medienberichten ist morgen seinen
medizin-check er soll einen
vierjahresvertrag erhalten
tennisprofi philipp kohlschreiber gab
sein karriereende bekannt zuvor hatte er
in wimbledon den sprung ins hauptfeld
verpasst seine beste
weltranglistenplatzierung war vor zehn
jahren rang 16 insgesamt gewann er ach
ttp turniere und eine tolle auszeichnung
gab es für eishockey nationalspieler
moritz leider in der nrz der 21 jährige
wurde als erster deutscher zum rookie
des jahres sind ja nordamerikanischen
profi liga gewählt in seiner debütsaison
bei den detroit red wings kam er auf
starke 50 scorerpunkte es ist verrückt
sagte mord sei denn erfurt mit eishockey
begann und in mannheim de l schüler
wurde der kann glaube ich ein ganz
großer werden dann vielen dank christian
sie wissen vielleicht in der vergangenen
nacht war sommersonnenwende die tage
werden bei uns jetzt wieder kürzer das
genaue gegenteil haben menschen auf der
südhalbkugel gefeiert in australien dort
werden die tage eben wieder länger mit
äußerst knapper kleidung wie sie sehen
feiern sie das auf der insel tasmanien
die körper entblößt die stimmung gelöst
ein bloßer badespaß mit roter haube und
ein kalter bei fünf grad celsius der
sinn des ganzen eine rituelle erneuerung
mit kühlem kopf und kälte schauer auf
der haut
ganz heiß dagegen wahrscheinlich die
zahlen vom mittwochslotto und die lauten
7 23
29 34
36 46 und die superzahl 5 weitere
gewinnzahlen auf lotto punkt zdf.de und
auf der zdf textseite 557
heute abend und in den nächsten tagen
entwickeln sich gewitter einzelheiten
gleich von katja horneffer zum heute
journal um 21.45 begrüßt sie später
christian sievers ja das war es von uns
morgen sind wir wieder für sie da
schönen dank und noch einen schönen für
sie
[Musik]
geht eine ständig durchfall
bauchschmerzen blähungen so oft kommen
kunden zu mir die unter reizdarm
beschwerden leiden was ist ein fehler
kijimea pro
kwh pro deinem gereizten darm
[Musik]
bei weihenstephan wird butter nicht
einfach nur verpackt dank unserer
einzigartigen frische verpackung bleibt
sie bis zum ersten öffnen geschützt und
entfaltet erst dann ihr volles aroma und
ihren frischen geschmack
es ist die sorgfalt die uns besonders
auszeichnet weihenstephan
sie leiden an brennenden schmerzen
häufig begleitet von kribbeln und
taubheitsgefühlen in beinen und füßen
dahinter stecken oft nervenschmerzen
hier hilft rest exil das arzneimittel
speziell bei nervenschmerzen rest exil
bei nervenschmerzen zu risiken und
nebenwirkungen lesen sie die
packungsbeilage und fragen sie ihren
arzt oder apotheker
woher kommt dieses
vereins wieder das nicht noch mal findet
gemeinsam angehen
[Musik]
der v versicherung du bist nicht allein
[Applaus]
deutschlands meistgekaufte matratze
jetzt bestellen auf bett1 de
[Musik]
guten abend nach der trockenen hitze vom
wochenende wird die luft jetzt von
südwesten immer schwüler hier fiel auch
regen viele von uns hatten heute aber
auch blauem himmel sonnenschein und über
schleswig-holstein zogen einige dichtere
wolkenfelder hinweg es gab kräftigen
regen in bayern und in baden württemberg
eigentlich dort wo der regen gar nicht
so dringend erforderlich ist und jetzt
zum abend und in der ersten nachthälfte
kann es auch mal für ein kurzes gewitter
reichen zum beispiel richtung hochrhein
oder auch richtung berchtesgadener land
die werden dann mehr und mehr in sich
zusammenfallen im norden ist es klar und
die temperaturen sinken auf werte
zwischen 17 grad am oberrhein und 8 grad
hier nordfriesland und morgen liegen die
höchsttemperaturen zwischen 22 grad an
der ostsee und 32 grad zum beispiel hier
in der nähe von hannover der vormittag
beginnt erstmal mit viel sonnenschein
und nur kleinen quellwolken das aber
ändert sich zum nachmittag wenn es dann
im schwarzwald hier in baden württemberg
am oberrhein aber auch westlich des
rheins für einige gewitter reichen wird
und dann kommt der unwetter freitag das
werden gewitter seien die mit hagel
platzregen und sturmböen verbunden sind
und die erreichen noch nicht den
äußersten osten zwischen dem erzgebirge
und ostsee
da kommen sie am samstag an guten abend